from Steven Spielberg comes the thriller
that earned him enough goodwill to make
up or a million crystal skulls Oh sir
treasure okay one Crystal Skull and
still stands as the best erected well
cast masterfully scored cheeseball B
movie ever made jaws experience one of
the scariest monster movies of all time
with barely any monster in it that
managed to scare the crap out of you
with just two music notes the occasional
fear and some barrels instead our three
powers because people didn't really have
a choice the truck was frustrating it
didn't really work all the time it
didn't work hardly at all thank God it
didn't work any more of that thing
would've made jaws one look like jaws
for
people are dying on Amity Island and
only one monster is to blame the town
mayor watches this horrible man and is
even more horrible Blazers do everything
they can to keep business going no
matter how many girls dogs children dogs
guys and other guys keep getting eaten
but those beaches will be open for this
weekend
we need summer dollars he is so getting
named in the class-action lawsuit after
this Kumar's the fourth of July and we
will be open for business out for
vengeance is chief Brody
a cop who wants to keep everyone safe
while getting a good buzz going and do
anything I'm the chief of points he'll
take to the sea with Hooper the original
Instagram hipster pull back for I need
to have something in the foreground
scale and Quint a grizzled old fish
encyclopedia blue gills Tommy Koch
violence stingray that's the threshing
see the chief threshers tail dogfish
it's got a couple of stripers orcas
talking about quarters watch as this
legendary badass sails out to do two
things kill sharks and sing sea shanties
well to you fair Spanish lady and he's
all out of sea
and he's all out of and he spies the
fire fairy me died at the age of 103 and
he school
and he's and he's dead
returned to the movie that invented the
summer blockbuster and inspired great
claustrophobic horror movies like alien
but also invented the unnecessary sequel
franchise fatigue and inspired every
sci-fi movie that combines sharks with
tornadoes and octopus for Tara Reid
so before you see the Spielberg film
about a Big Friendly Giant revisit the
film about a big ensure that made
everyone scare to go in the water
even though sharks kill fewer people per
year than being crushed by a vending
machine that proves you don't need fancy
CGI to make a great blockbuster just one
of the best living directors a perfect
cast and one of the most iconic scores
of all time that actually sounds pretty
hard now I get why they stick with CGI
starring Seaquest 70s Paul Giamatti
Captain Ahab
when you fish upon a star the Universal
Studios tour this guy tiger shark a was
the part that makes you poop your pants
legs more legs and seriously what is
with this movie legs shark tail
you know the book this was based on was
set on the Jersey Shore right that would
have been a way different movie get a
shark get um our contest to win a trip
to San Diego might be over but we are
happy to announce that all of you can
attend screen junkie central as we'll be
screaming all the action live and free
on screen junkies calm and best of all
you don't have to be in San Diego so
join us for our exclusive shows and
celebrity events from the comfort of
your own home in your underwear or less
all you have to do is click on the
register button on screen junkies comm
slash central by doing so you'll get
early access to tickets to our live
shows celebrity guests announcements
streaming schedules and full access to
all our content that's being filmed in
San Diego so go and register now
you're gonna need a bigger boat
help I'm being held captive in spring
junky Studios mission failed we'll get
them next time r+ l equals j a raven
came from the citadel a white raven
winter is here so did uh did you guys
click on the link to register yet come
on let me look desperate